rising tension in the clark county
school district and a principal writes a
letter
in support of the superintendent
and brian that breaks away from the
administrator's union which is calling
for dr jarrah's resignation
8 news now reporter kristen drummond has
the latest for us
i don't have time for adult issues i'm
here for kids
and i wanted to put that out there
dondero elementary school principal
melanie poster wants to balance the
conversation about terminating
superintendent dr jesus jarrah
a meeting about jaw's job is scheduled
for wednesday
i think it's important that all sides
are visible to the board
she wrote this three-page letter that's
now circulating online
after talking with union colleagues it
says in part
i learned that the bigger picture is to
try and remove dr jarrah as
superintendent before
january of the next legislative year not
one person
said that it was because he was a poor
instructional leader it was all politics
she also criticizes the leadership of
danielle ford and accuses her of
spending the better part of two years
doing a smear campaign against the
superintendent
it's simply feedback in order to move
forward for with our kids best interest
the executive director of the clark
county education association
also criticizing trustee ford during a
recent podcast
the moment she was hired she represented
to our organization
that she was going to run candidates in
2020
that she was going to take control of
the board
have a majority of support be elected
president of the board and bring her own
people
in she told us that that was almost two
years ago i reached out to trustee ford
for a comment
she says some groups are encouraging
people to speak up about things that are
unrelated
to distract from the topic at hand in
the newsroom kristen drummond
8 news now meantime the non-profit
hope for nevada shared that letter
online the vice president says
more principals are reaching out after
disagreeing with the administrators
union
now we emailed the union about the
situation and did not get a response
back